Dieser Podcast wird Ihnen von der LMU
München zu dieser Vorlesung zur Verfügung gestellt und ich werde
Ihnen nur die dritte und letzte
Vorlesung von Brendham vorstellen und er wird
heute Abend über den letzten Teil, die
Schlusspassagen der Einführung und
den Titel von folgt dem Pfad sprechen  der
Verzweiflung oder des kanadischen Rebellen das
Auftauchen der zweiten beiden Optionen. Nun,
ich weiß, dass diejenigen von Ihnen, die
so lange bei mir geblieben sind, dieses Zeug wirklich ernst nehmen,
also schätze ich es, also
eröffnet Hegel die Einführung in die
Phänomenologie, indem er ein
erkenntnistheoretisches Bild betrachtet  nach
der unsere kognitiven Fähigkeiten
als das Instrument betrachtet werden, durch das
man das Absolute ergreift, oder als das
Medium, durch das man es entdeckt, können
Philosophen, die sonst so unterschiedlich sind wie
Descartes Locke und Kant
, mit Versionen dieses Bildes arbeiten, und
es scheint klar zu sein  dass Hegel meint, wir
müssten aus der Enge
dieses Denkens über Dinge ausbrechen, die er
dennoch in meinem f als natürlich bezeichnet  Im ersten
Vortrag habe ich versucht zu sagen, warum und
allgemein die Form
des neuen Bildes zu beschreiben, das er
empfehlen wird, um diesem
traditionellen nachzufolgen
Sündenbock für Skepsis, genauer gesagt,
er denkt, dass die traditionelle Moderne der
Histologie im
Rahmen semantischer Annahmen betrieben wird, die es
letztendlich unmöglich machen, das zu erfüllen, was ich
jetzt die allgemeine
Erkenntnisbedingung nannte, dies ist die
Anforderung, die die erkenntnistheoretische
Theorie nicht stellt  unverständlich, dass
zumindest wenn alles gut
läuft, wie die Dinge uns erscheinen, wie sie wirklich
in seinen Begriffen sind, dass, wie die Dinge für das
Bewusstsein sind, so sein kann, wie die Dinge an
sich sind. Ich argumentierte, dass das entscheidende
Merkmal der Klasse von Theorien, die er
annimmt  verfehlen diese Anforderung, indem
sie die Verständlichkeit
echten Wissens ausschließen, nicht, dass sie
die Beziehung zwischen ap auslegen  Erfahrung
und Realität in Repräsentationsbegriffen ist es,
dass sie den Begriff und ich der
Beziehung nehmen, die durch einen
strukturellen Unterschied gekennzeichnet ist, der die Erscheinungen repräsentiert,
konstruiert wird, ist
konzeptionell artikuliert, gut
repräsentierte Realitäten sind keine Theorien,
mit dieser Form ausgehobene Kluft der
Verständlichkeit, die das Wissen
vom Bekannten trennt  Denken Sie jetzt von der Welt an all die
Unterschiede, die es geben könnte, wie
die bekannte Welt objektiv ist, und wie
das wissende Subjekt sie darstellt, warum
sollte man denken, dass dieser mögliche
Unterschied einen solchen Unterschied macht, warum
sollte es eine Rolle spielen, wenn das Denken, aber nicht die
Welt, über die gedacht wird, ist  Hegels
Arbeiten in einem kontinuierlichen Diem, in dem
es eine interne Verbindung zwischen
konzeptueller Artikulation und
Verständnis gibt, sind die Form eines
wahrnehmenden Bewusstseins, so dass das, was verstanden werden kann,
verständlich ist,
was in konzeptueller Form ist, was Hegel glaubt
, es sei denn  Bild hat es, dass wir
c  Um zu verstehen, wie die Dinge wirklich sind, muss jede
Beziehung, die wir zwischen diesen
Realitäten in den Erscheinungen behaupten, die wir
verstehen oder begreifen können, selbst
unverständlich sein,
keine Beziehung zu dem, was letztendlich und
intrinsisch
unverständlich ist, weil nicht konzeptionell
artikuliert als kognitive
Beziehung gelten könnte, könnte sie nicht die Grundlage sein  Für
eine Darstellung des Wissens, die
die Möglichkeit echten Wissens sinnvoll macht, ist
dies das Problem mit der Idee
, die Wahrheit in ihrer Reinheit zu erhalten
, indem man einfach vom Ergebnis
die Instrumente abzieht, die an dieser
Repräsentation des Absoluten beteiligt sind, die
wir dadurch gewonnen haben  und für das Zitat wäre
das Ergebnis der Subtraktion seiner konzeptionellen
Form von unserem Verständnis
etwas Unverständliches. Wir können
die Beziehung zwischen dem, was
verständlich ist, und dem, was nicht verständlich ist,
aus dem einfachen Grund nicht verstehen, dass wir nicht
verstehen können,
dass ein solches Bild
nicht verständlich ist.  t erfüllen die
Bedingung für echtes Wissen auch in my  Im ersten
Vortrag schlug ich vor, dass der Schlüssel zu dem
alternativen Bild, das Hegel aufstellen möchte,
in der nichtpsychologischen
Konzeption des Begrifflichen liegt, die er
im Bewusstseinsabschnitt der Phänomenologie einführt und entwickelt.
Gemäß dieser
Konzeption werden begriffliche Inhalte
durch Relationen materieller
Inkompatibilität artikuliert  ist eine bestimmte Negation
oder ausschließliche Differenz, das ist die
aristotelische Gegensätzlichkeit. Dieser
Gedankengang beginnt mit einem Verständnis von
bestimmten Necedah-Gedanken und
Dingen, die in Spinozas Diktum über
dieses Bestimmte hier kodifiziert sind, da ich Ihnen sowohl gesagt habe,
dass es eine bestimmte Art und Weise gibt, wie die
Welt ist und dass a  Gedanken einen
bestimmten Inhalt haben, sind
im Sinne dessen zu verstehen, welche Möglichkeiten sie
einen Sachverhalt ausschließen, dessen
Erlangen das Erlangen
von keinem anderen ausschließen würde ein Gedanke, dessen Wahrheit
die Wahrheit von keinem anderen ausschließen würde, wäre
unbestimmt winbush bedämpft die Art der
Verneinung  in Bezug auf die Bestimmung
ist  In Hegels Version von
Spinozas Denken ist zu verstehen, dass die charakterisierenden
Beziehungen dessen, was er
exklusive Hausanständige Differenz nennt, im Gegensatz zu
indifferenter glykolytischer Differenz, das
heißt, es ist die Beziehung zwischen kreisförmig
und dreieckig, nicht die zwischen kreisförmig
und rot, diese Art des Verständnisses der
Metaphysik der Determinante ist
keineswegs idiosynkratisch für Hegel, abgesehen von seinen
scholastischen und
scholastischen Vorläufern, ist es der Leitgedanke der
zeitgenössischen Informationstheorie, die
die durch
ein Signal vermittelte Information im Hinblick auf die Möglichkeiten versteht, die
ihr Empfang für ihren Empfänger ausschließt
und als eine andere Art und Weise verstanden werden kann
das Verständnis eines
Satzes als Aufteilung möglicher
Welten in solche auszudrücken, die
mit seiner Wahrheit kompatibel und solche sind, die mit seiner Wahrheit nicht kompatibel sind,
aber dennoch welche Berechtigung besteht,
an diese metaphysische Konzeption
einer bestimmten Nasteria-Land-
Kompatibilität als eine Konzeption des
Begriffs zu denken, nur um dieses Iden zu finden
tifizierung erfordert, zunächst
zwei bestimmende Merkmale des
Begrifflichen darzulegen, wenn wir zeigen, wie man
die kontinente
Enttafikation der Verständlichkeit in
Begriffsform begründen kann, indem man sagt, was es heißt,
etwas zu erfassen oder zu verstehen, das
in dieser Begriffsform ist  Sinn für
begriffliche Form Zweitens, wenn wir zeigen, wie
das begriffliche Inhaltliche in diesem
Sinne auch Darstellungsgehalt aufweist,
so entsprechen die beiden
Dimensionen der Intentionalität, die
ich letztes Mal unterschieden habe, der
Intentionalität und der Intentionalität,
was man denken und sagen kann und was man
dabei möchte  Über meinen zweiten Vortrag nachzudenken oder zu sprechen, ging
genau auf diese beiden Fragen ein, ausgehend von
der Vorstellung von begrifflichen Inhalten, wie
sie durch materielle Inkompatibilitätsverhältnisse artikuliert wurden
, zeigte er sowohl, was
man tun muss, um damit als kognitives Erfassen solcher Inhalte zu gelten, als auch,
worauf
es hinausläuft
die gegenständliche
p praktisch anerkennend  bedeutung dieser inhalte das
begreifen oder verstehen eines begriffsinhalts ist das
eingreifen in einen prozess der erfahrung
dies ist hegels nachfolgekonzept zum
inhalt bei der wahrnehmung unter urteilen wiederum versteht man bei Kant, was man
tun muss, um wahrzunehmen
kognitiv bewusst zu sein
rationales
Integrieren einer Verpflichtung in ein sich
entwickelndes Ganzes, das die
unverwechselbare synthetische Einheit einer
Wahrnehmung aufweist, dass Einheit eine rationale
Einheit mit kritischen AmpliTube- und
rechtfertigenden Q-Tory-Dimensionen ist
, die der normativen Verpflichtung entsprechen, materiell unvereinbare Verpflichtungen zu extrudieren
, materielle Konsequenzen anzuerkennen und
Behauptungen zu beurteilen, die Inhalte rechtfertigen
Bindungen besitzen müssen, um
diesen rationalen normativen Verpflichtungen unterworfen zu sein,
müssen dementsprechend in
Relationen materieller Inkompatibilität
und Konsequenz zu anderen
stehen  es,
was es konzeptionell ausschließt, was eine
materielle Folge davon ist, was es
konzeptionell
beinhaltet und was es eine materielle
Folge dessen ist, was konzeptionell
beinhaltet, und das heißt nur, dass
es notwendig und ausreichend ist,
in diesem Sinne fassbar zu sein, um
wahrnehmbar zu sein, was die Inhalte sind
bestimmt im Sinne von
in Beziehungen bestimmter
Negation und damit Vermittlung zueinander stehen,
was in diesem Sinne bestimmt ist, ist
in Begriffsform und Knöchelsinn In seiner
Einleitung konzentriert sich Hegel auf eine
Dimension des Prozesses einer Wahrnehmungserfahrung
, die Erfahrung von Fehlern dieser
Art  der Erfahrung wird dadurch verursacht
, dass man sich selbst mit materiell
unvereinbaren Verpflichtungen
wiederfindet den Fehler praktisch
anerkennt seine kritische Aufgabe wahrnimmt die Verantwortung, ihn zu
beheben die Unvereinbarkeit zu beseitigen,
indem mindestens
eine der miteinander unvereinbaren
Verpflichtungen aufgegeben oder geändert wird Ich habe im vorherigen Vortrag
erklärt, wie es dazu kommt  die Erfahrung
von  Irrtum, wie es in der Erfahrung des
Irrtums ist, dass der Repräsentationsgehalt
praktisch das
Bestimmte, also den begrifflichen Inhalt
, angenommen hat
unmöglich ist, dass sie
von einem auf demselben Objekt ausgestellt werden sollten,
wenn man
zwei verschiedenen Objekten unvereinbare Eigenschaften zuschreibt, man
sich noch nicht geirrt hat,
man hat einen Fehler gemacht, aber die
Verpflichtungen sind unvereinbar, sich auf
sie zu beziehen  oder
in der zweiten Phase
der Fehlererfahrung ein Subjekt in demselben Objekt darstellt, reagiert ein Subjekt
auf das Eingeständnis des Fehlers, indem es
die kritische
Aufgabenverantwortung erfüllt, die
Inkohärenz zu beheben, indem es
eine der Verpflichtungen ändert oder verwirft, indem es
die geänderten oder verworfenen behandelt
Engagement als bloßer Schein und das
Bewahrte und Ergebnisi  ng Verpflichtungen zum
Ausdruck zu bringen, wie die Dinge wirklich sind, wird
auf diese Weise durch die Erfahrung des
Irrtums die Unterscheidung zwischen dem, was die
Dinge an sich Realität sind, und dem,
was die Dinge nur für das Bewusstsein sind, der
Erscheinung selbst etwas zu
bewusst,
dass die Unterscheidung praktisch
in dem Prozess enthalten ist, der die Erfahrung ist  des
Irrtums, so nimmt das
Bewusstsein als grundlegenden
Aspekt seiner Funktionsstruktur eine praktische
Wertschätzung seiner Determinanten auf,
objektive Verpflichtungen, die vorgeben zu
repräsentieren, wie die Dinge wirklich objektiv
sind, es behandelt seine Verpflichtungen als über
Dinge in dem Sinne, dass es darauf antwortet, wie die
Dinge sind  sich für die
Richtigkeit der Sachlage zu schlagen, so erfüllt
Hegel Spinozas Begriffsbegriff der
Bestimmtheit im Sinne der
Artikulation durch Relationen modal
robusten Ausschlussmaterials in
Kompatibilität oder bestimmter Negation
die prinzipiellen Anforderungen an einen
Metabegriff begrifflicher
Gehaltsfülle, die er sinnvoll macht  Die Frage, was es heißt
, einen begrifflichen Inhalt zu erfassen und was
es bedeutet, dass solche Inhalte eine
repräsentative Dimension haben, und
die Art und Weise, wie diese beiden Kriterien der
Angemessenheit erfüllt werden, sind
im Kontext von Hegels
Strukturkritik der traditionellen modernen
Erkenntnistheorie die Schlüsselerklärung  Der
Vorteil dieser nicht-psychologischen Konzeption
des Konzeptuellen liegt darin, dass es nicht
nur auf subjektive Gedanken, sondern auch auf
objektive Tatsachen zutrifft, denn beide sind determiniert,
sie sind determinierte Art und Weise, wie das Bewusstsein
die Dinge annimmt, und sie sind
determinierend, wie die Dinge sind, und beide
aufgrund ihres Status  In Beziehungen
materieller Inkompatibilität gibt es zwei andere
Möglichkeiten, Dinge zu sein oder Dinge
zu sein, aber das subjektive und
objektive Gefühl der materiellen
Inkompatibilität sind nicht dasselbe, wenn zwei
Sachverhalte materiell
unvereinbar sind, dann ist es unmöglich,
beide zu erhalten, aber wenn zwei Gedanken  oder
Urteile materiell unvereinbar sind,
folgt daraus keineswegs, dass dies der Fall ist
unmöglich für ein Subjekt,
gleichzeitig beiden verpflichtet zu sein, folgt nur,
dass das Subjekt so
verpflichtet sein sollte, dass ein solches Subjekt verpflichtet ist
, etwas zu tun, um die Situation zu ändern
, um die ständige kritische Aufgabe zu erfüllen, die
Verantwortung zu erfüllen, die Situation zu korrigieren
, indem die Inkohärenz beseitigt wird
Die Seite von Objekten Inkompatibilität
von Eigenschaften ist eine analytische modale
Angelegenheit seiner
Möglichkeit auf der Website von Subjekten
Subjekte Inkompatibilität von Verpflichtungen
ist eine technisch normative Angelegenheit von
Unangemessenheit, aber der Begriff von Material
in Kompatibilität oder bestimmender Negation
, der in diesen beiden Geschmacksrichtungen vorkommt, ist es nicht
einfach zweideutig, denn was man tun muss,
um damit als praktisch
zwei objektive
Eigenschaften oder Sachverhalte als
objektiv unvereinbar zu nehmen oder zu behandeln, ist gerade,
die entsprechenden Bindungen als
normativ unvereinbar in dem Sinne zu behandeln,
dass man sich mit beiden verpflichtet,
die eigene ändern will  Verpflichtungen in
Anerkennung  Die Feststellung eines Fehlers, der zwei Festlegungen behandelt,
ist in der
heutigen Zeit unvereinbar. Ein normativer Sinn ist die
Darstellung zweier Eigenschaften oder
Sachverhalte als unvereinbar im Sinne des Aletha-
Modals  sich angemessen mit ihnen
in der Praxis oder im Prozess der Erfahrung,
insbesondere der Erfahrung von Fehlern, zu beschäftigen, indem
man seiner Verpflichtung nachkommt, anerkannte Unvereinbarkeiten zu lösen
, indem man unvereinbare
Verpflichtungen als unvereinbare
Sachverhalte behandelt, die Beziehung zwischen
dem Gefühl von materiell unvereinbar
, das durch deontische normative Beziehungen artikuliert wird
wozu
man auf der subjektiven Seite der
Repräsentation x' verpflichtet oder berechtigt ist, was die Dinge für das
Bewußtsein sind, und der
durch dicke modale
Beziehungen artikulierte Sinn dessen, was
auf der objektiven Seite der Repräsentanten notwendig und möglich ist,
was die Dinge an sich sind
, ist eins  von rec  Iprokale
Sinnabhängigkeit ist es nicht so, dass es keine
objektiven Eigenschaften und
Sachverhalte geben kann, die in modalen
und kompatiblen Beziehungen zueinander stehen, es sei denn,
sie würden x' von ihnen repräsentieren,
sondern dass man nicht verstehen kann,
was man sagt oder denkt, wenn man es sagt
oder denken, dass sie in solchen
Beziehungen stehen, es sei denn als Teil einer Geschichte, die
beinhaltet, welche Subjekte
sie so darstellen, dass sie praktisch
ihre normative Verpflichtung anerkennen
, etwas zu tun, um die Situation zu reparieren,
wenn sie sich mit
Verpflichtungen gegenüber Objekten mit Einkommenseigenschaften
oder unvereinbar finden
Sachverhalte allgemeiner ist dieses Verhältnis der
wechselseitigen Sinnabhängigkeit
für den janusköpfigen
Charakter von Hegels Metabegriff der
bestimmten Negation verantwortlich: Einerseits
charakterisiert es die Aletha-Modalbeziehungen,
die einzigen Denkmodalbeziehungen, die als
con gelehrt die objektive Welt strukturieren
andererseits charakterisiert es die
Norm regelt  subjektiver Prozess oder
Praxis, die Erfahrung ist, die
in Terraria immer die Erfahrung des
Irrtums ist, in letzterem Aspekt handelt es sich nicht
um statische Beziehungen, sondern um ein dynamisches
Prinzip der Bewegungsveränderung und
-entwicklung, von dem man
die grundlegendste Struktur der
objektiven Welt nicht verstehen kann  Zu verstehen,
was man tun muss, um die Dinge so darzustellen
, ist ein wesentliches Element von
Hegels Idealismus. Man
kann sagen, dass objektive Substanzen nicht
weniger als Subjekte, nicht weniger als
Gedanken als bestimmte Wesen wesentlich
begrifflich strukturiert sind, aber wenn man
sich nicht daran erinnert  komplexe Feinstruktur
von Hegels janusgesichtiger nichtpsychologischer
Konzeption des Begrifflichen im Sinne von
determinierter 'kein Sartre ikkyu liert durch
materielle Inkompatibilität der beiden
Arten wird man nicht verstehen, was
mit einer solchen Behauptung gemeint ist, in der nun die größte
hermeneutische Herausforderung bei der Lektüre der
Einleitung liegt  die drei
Absätze, die dem Finale vorangehen  e
denn hier stellt Hegel zwei Behauptungen auf, die
überraschend genug sind, um ausführlich zitiert zu werden,
und die Sie auf dem
Handzettel finden werden. Die erste wird mit der Bemerkung eingeleitet,
dass wir uns in die
Lage versetzt haben, das in der
Erfahrung des Irrtums zu verstehen  das Subjekt
Bewusstsein Zitat ist Bewusstsein dessen,
was ihm das Wahre ist, und
Bewusstsein seiner Kenntnis dieser Wahrheit, da
beide für Bewusstsein sind
Das Bewusstsein
selbst tendiert zu dem Zitat, dass das Subjekt
den Mann
Tyrael als vereinbar mit seinen Verpflichtungen einschätzt
, seine kritische rationale Aufgabe ausübt, seine
Verantwortung als Richter wahrnimmt, wenn eine
Unvereinbarkeit festgestellt wird, eine Wahl getroffen werden
muss, aber eine Verpflichtung immer noch
bestätigt werden kann, da sie darstellt, wie die Dinge an sich wirklich
sind  dann müssen andere
als bloße Erscheinungen entlarvt werden, die
jetzt implizit praktisch sind  Wenn Sie das so behandelten
, als würde es nur darstellen, wie die
Dinge für das Bewusstsein sind, erinnern Sie sich hier an
die entscheidende Unterscheidung, die, wie ich
im zweiten Vortrag Hegel
Marx grammatikalisch dargelegt habe, zwischen dem, was
die Dinge implizit für das Bewusstsein sind,
und dem, was sie explizit
für das Bewusstsein sind  Das Beispiel aus
der letzten Vorlesung, das sein Verhalten sieht,
wenn der halb eingetauchte Stock vollständig
aus dem Wasser entfernt wird, das
Subjekt seine Verpflichtung, gebogen zu sein,
aufgibt und durch eine Verpflichtung ersetzt
, gerade zu sein. Es ist nur leicht
übertrieben zu sagen, dass das Bewusstsein
das Subjekt ist  Von dieser Erfahrung
ist ihr Vergleich, sagt Hegel, etwas
ist das An sich, aber das Wissen
oder das Sein des Objekts für das
Bewusstsein ist ihm noch ein weiterer Moment, es liegt an
dieser Differenzierung,
die in seiner Gegenwart vorhanden ist, dass
die Untersuchung der Pugh-Schaum ist
geerdet und wenn in diesem Vergleich die
beiden Momente nicht übereinstimmen, dann
scheint es so  Das Bewusstsein muss
sein Wissen ändern, um es
in Einklang mit dem Objektende des
Zitats zu bringen, das heißt, nachdem die Diskrepanz
behoben wurde und die materielle
Inkompatibilität den Anschein wiederhergestellt hat,
was die Dinge für das Bewusstsein sein sollten
, soweit es das Bewusstsein betrifft
wurden
mit der Realität in Einklang gebracht, was die Dinge an sich sind
, aber so möchte Hegel nicht,
dass wir verstehen und darüber sprechen,
was in einer solchen Erfahrung passiert, sagt er,
in der Veränderung des Wissens wird
das Objekt selbst jedoch zum
Bewusstsein zu etwas, das darin ist
Tatsache wurde auch geändert, denn
das vorhandene Wissen war im Wesentlichen
ein Wissen des Objekts.
Mit der Änderung des Wissens wird das Objekt
auch zu einem anderen, da es ein
wesentlicher Teil dieses Wissens war
an sich
ist nicht an sich, oder was an sich
war, war es nur für das Bewußtsein, wenn es sich darauf
bezieht  Findet das Bewusstsein sein
Wissen nicht mit seinem Objekt korrespondierend, so
wird auch das Objekt selbst
nachgeben, d. h. die Standard-
Meisteraufgabe der Prüfung wird geändert, wenn das
, dessen Standard es sein sollte,
den Verlauf der Prüfung nicht übersteht,
also die Prüfung ist  nicht nur die
Prüfung des Wissens, sondern auch der
bei der Prüfung selbst verwendete Standard.
Das Ende des Zitats. Nun, das ist sehr
seltsam, warum sollten wir denken, dass, wenn
ein Subjekt sich verpflichtet hat, auszudrücken,
wie die Dinge wirklich sind, eine Darstellung dessen ist,
wie die Dinge sind  an sich, was
es für das Subjekt war,
als sich herausstellte, dass eine solche Verpflichtung lediglich ausdrückt,
wie die Dinge für das Bewusstsein sind,
warum sollten wir denken, dass sich die Realität
ändert, wenn ich merke, dass der Stock, den
ich zum Biegen hielt, wirklich seltsam ist, meine
Sicht auf den Stock  ändert sich aber der Stock
selbst nicht, dass ich ihn für
gebogen hielt, ist in unserer gewöhnlichen
Denkweise sicher kein wesentliches Merkmal des
Stockes das Objekt  Nur
aus dem,
was man mit Recht behaupten könnte, dass
sein Gegenstand der Stock ein wesentliches
Merkmal des Erscheinungsbildes war, folgt nicht
die
gegenteilige Behauptung  Aber in welchem
ändert sich dieser Standard, wenn ich merke
dass meine Formv
rpflichtung nicht dem Standard entspricht, dass es fa
sch ist?  im
W
ein Wissen des Objekts mit einer Änderung
des Wissens wird das Objekt auch zu einem
anderen, weil es ein wesentlicher
Teil dieses Wissens war, dass das Argument
auf einer offensichtlich ungerechtfertigten Rutschbahn zu tauschen scheint,
selbst wenn wir das zugeben, was es eine
Behauptung darüber ist, was es darstellt
für die Identität des Anspruchs wesentlich ist,
so dass eine Änderung des dargestellten Objekts
den Inhalt des Anspruchs ändern würde,
d  Daraus folgt nicht, dass der Inhalt
des Anspruchs entsprechend wesentlich
für die Identität des dargestellten
Objekts ist, so dass eine Änderung des Inhalts
des Anspruchs das Objekt ändert, für das
wesentlich ist, im Allgemeinen keine
symmetrische Beziehung ist, so dass wir beispielsweise
denken könnten, dass die Identität von  meine
eltern sind wesentlich für meine identität
jeder mit anderen eltern
wäre jemand anders als ich es ist
nicht möglich, dass ich
andere eltern hatte, aber wenn wir
uns das umgekehrte ansehen, scheint es
möglich, dass meine eltern nie welche
hatten  Kinder oder hatten nur
einige der Kinder, die sie mich nicht eingeschlossen
haben. Wesentlichkeit der Herkunft von Menschen
bedeutet nicht Wesentlichkeit von
Nachkommen. Es ist leicht zu sehen, dass Hegel hier
einen Taschenspielertrick betreibt, der
versucht, selbstgefällig und unbeobachtet einen
unglaubwürdigen Idealismus zu machen, der das
macht, was ist  darüber nachgedacht ist wesentlich
für die Identität dessen, worüber nachgedacht wird,
aber wie wir sehen werden, wäre das ein
Missverständnis des c  Behauptung, dass er
die zweite überraschende Behauptung aufstellt,
wird als Teil einer Darstellung der
Grundstruktur der Erfahrung in dem
charakteristischen technischen Sinn
eingeführt, den Hegel hier einführt, um diese dialektische
Bewegung zu zitieren, die das Bewusstsein
auf sich selbst ausübt, sowohl auf sein Wissen als auch auf
sein Objekt, insofern das
Als Ergebnis davon entsteht dem Bewusstsein ein neuer wahrer Gegenstand,
genau das, was
Erfahrung genannt wird, und an das Zitat wird hier die
Herausforderung der früheren
Passage angelehnt, wie wir die Bewegung verstehen sollen,
die das Bewusstsein
auf das Objekt seiner Erkenntnis ausübt,
die Schlüsselfrage  wird sich als dies herausstellen,
wenn das Bekenntnis zum Stock
verbogen wird und durch das
Bekenntnis zum Stock ersetzt wird, da gerade, was
genau das neue Objekt ist, die
richtige Beantwortung dieser Frage
wesentlich ist, um zu verstehen,
in welchem Sinne nach Hegels Darstellung der Repräsenta
ionsgehalt von begrifflich
ist  Inhalt 'voller Einsatz ist selbst
etwas zum Bewußtsein impl  icit in
seinem eigenen Erfahrungsprozess
, um die Berechtigung dafür zu verstehen
, dass die Erfahrung des
Irrtums nicht nur die Bindung des
Subjekts an die Dinge verändert, da der Stock
jetzt als gerade und nicht als gebogen angesehen
wird, was er Bewusstseinswissen nennt,
sondern auch  Das Objekt dieses
Wissens,
der wesentliche Punkt, den es zu erkennen gilt, ist, dass
das neue wahre Objekt, von dem er sagt
, dass es im Bewusstsein auftaucht, nicht der
gerade Stock ist, schließlich hat es sich nicht
geändert, es war die ganze Zeit gerade. Hegel
beschreibt das Bewusstsein wie die
Erfahrung wie dieses Zitat Bewusstsein
weiß etwas und dieses Objekt ist die
Essenz oder das an sich, aber dieses Objekt
ist auch das an sich für das Bewusstsein
und daher kommt die Mehrdeutigkeit dieser Wahrheit
ins Spiel, wir sehen, dass das Bewusstsein
jetzt zwei Objekte hat, eines ist das erste an
sich und das zweite ist  das Sein zum
Bewußtsein dieses an sich selbst
scheint zunächst nur die
Reflexion des Bewußtseins in sich selbst zu sein,
ein Repräsentant  Ressentiment nicht über ein Objekt, sondern
nur über seine Kenntnis des ersten
Objekts, sondern hat bereits angedeutet, dass das
erste Objekt für das Bewusstsein verändert wird,
in diesem Prozess
hört es auf, das Ansich zu sein, und wird
für das Bewusstsein ein Objekt, das
nur das Ansich ist  denn daraus und daraus
folgt, dass dies das Sein zum
Bewußtsein dieses an sich das
Wahre ist, das heißt, dieses Wahre ist
das Wesen oder Bewußtsein neuer
Gegenstand dieser neue Gegenstand enthält die
Vernichtung des ersten es ist die
durch den ersten konstituierte Erfahrung
Objekt schließen Zitat
Das erste, was zu bemerken ist, ist meiner Meinung nach,
dass das erste Objekt als
das erste an sich beschrieben wird, was impliziert, dass
es mindestens ein weiteres
an sich gibt, aber es gibt nur einen echten
Stock, und es ist verirrt. Der Schlüssel zum
Verständnis ist, worum es geht
hier ist die rolle, die etwas
in der erfahrung spielen kann die rolle, um die es
geht, ist ein an sich zum bewusstsein
zu sein ein an sich zum bewusstsein zu sein ist
zu sein, was das Bewusstsein
zu Beginn der Erfahrung praktisch für real hält oder behandelt,
das
betreffende Subjekt unterstützt die Behauptung, dass der
Stock gebogen ist, was das
Subjekt für real hält, dass der gebogene
Stock das erste in sich selbst
zum Bewusstsein ausdrückt, wie es anfänglich ist
Dinge wirklich objektiv als das
Zweite an sich zum Bewußtsein nimmt
, wird durch die spätere Befürwortung des geraden Stocks ausgedrückt,
aber was ist dann das zweite
Objekt, von dem in diesen Passagen die Rede ist?
zweites Objekt ist das Sein für das
Bewusstsein des ersten an sich
was bedeutet das, wenn er
die Bewegung der Erfahrung im
vorigen Absatz einführt, sagt Hegel Zitat
daher gilt für das Bewusstsein, dass das,
was ihm das an sich war,
nicht an sich ist  oder was an sich
war, war nur für das Bewusstsein so Ende des
Zitats Was das Subjekt entdeckt, ist das
WHA  Um auszudrücken, wie die
Dinge wirklich sind, drückt der Pflock
eigentlich nur eine Erscheinung aus,
die Rolle, die die verbogene
Stockdarstellung für das Bewusstsein spielt, was sie zum
Bewusstsein verändert hat,
wird sie zum Bewusstsein ein Objekt
, das an sich die einzige Stirn ist  und für
das Zitat ist das, was er das neue wahre Objekt nennt, die
Darstellung des gebogenen Stocks, die
sich als falsch herausgestellt hat, als eine
falsche Darstellung dessen, was für das Subjekt jetzt so ist, wie
die Dinge wirklich ein
gerader Stock sind. Diese Darstellung ist
nicht wahr im Sinne der Darstellung, wie die
Dinge wirklich sind  sind, aber in dem Sinne, dass
das, was es jetzt für das Bewusstsein
ist, das ist, was es wirklich ist, eine bloße Erscheinung, eine
falsche Darstellung, deshalb enthält dieses neue Objekt, das ich zitiere,
die Vernichtung
des ersten, es ist die Erfahrung,
die durch dieses erste Objekt konstituiert wird,
Ende des Zitats
das ist der Sinn, in dem Zitat in der
Veränderung des Wissens das Objekt
selbst zum Bewußtsein wird
, was hineingehört  Tatsache wurde ebenfalls geändert.
Zitat schließen
Was sich ändert, ist der Status des gebogenen
Stocks, der darstellt, was er für das
Bewusstsein ist. Er genoss den
Status, für das Bewusstsein zu sein, was der
Stock an sich ist, aber jetzt hat sich sein Status
dahingehend geändert, dass er für das Bewusstsein nur das ist,
was er ist  Stock war für Bewusstsein und
Erscheinung. Verstehen der zwei Objekte.
Verstehen, dass die zwei Objekte
die Repräsentation des gebogenen Stocks sind, als
es gebilligt wurde, und die Repräsentation des gebogenen
Stocks, wenn es nicht mehr
gebilligt wird
zitiere Wissen über das
Objekt im Argument zitiere für
das vorhandene Wissen war im Wesentlichen
ein Wissen über das Objekt mit Veränderung
des Wissens wird das Objekt auch zu einem
anderen, da es ein wesentlicher Teil
dieser Wissensklasse war zitiere was
Wissen ist – Bewusstsein ist was ist
befürwortet, was das Subjekt praktisch oder
implizit dafür hält, wie die Dinge wirklich
sind, was bewusst sein muss  Dass sich der Status
des Wissens im Laufe
der Erfahrung vom Sein der Stange hat sich
zum Stock als gerade gebogen verändert, das war die
Erkenntnis des Objekts nicht in dem Sinne,
in dem ein Darstellen von etwas
Repräsentiertem ist, sondern in dem Sinne, dass der
Status zu sein ist  Bewusstsein Wissen
wurde von dem Objekt besessen oder gezeigt die
Repräsentation des gebogenen Stocks dass der
Status von diesem Objekt besessen wurde der
konzeptionelle Inhalt ist in der Tat wesentlich
für dieses Wissen wenn der Status
mit etwas anderem verbunden ist eine
Repräsentation des geraden Stocks ist es in einem
einfachen Sinne ein
anderes Wissen was  Objekt hier
entscheidend in dem Sinne, an welchen
konzeptuellen Inhalt es anknüpft, ist
wesentlich für sein Sein, dass das Wissen
, das das Wissen ändert, indem es einen
anderen unvereinbaren Inhalt bestätigt,
den Status des ursprünglichen Inhalts
ändert und so das ändert, was er das Objekt nennt, das
mit dem ursprünglichen Wissen verbunden ist
Status ändert sich von einem konzeptionellen
Inhalt, der bestätigt wird, zu sein  g eine
, die jetzt abgelehnt wird. Ich denke, Hegel
hätte hier Verwirrung sinnvollerweise vermeiden
können, indem er entweder diesen neuen Sinn des Wissensgegenstands nicht so eingeführt hätte
, dass er nicht das meint,
was durch das Wissen repräsentiert wird, sondern
den konzeptionellen Inhalt des Wissens,
oder indem er erklärt, dass er
den Begriff so verwendet  an dieser Stelle
hilft er uns aber nicht weiter, aber so
gelesen wird die erste ursprünglich überraschende
Behauptung, so wird die zweite
überraschende Behauptung nicht mehr eine, die Hegel
selbst als solche kennzeichnet, sagt er Zitat in
dieser Darstellung des
Erfahrungsverlaufs gibt es eine  Moment,
aufgrund dessen es keine
Übereinstimmung mit der gewöhnlichen Verwendung des
Begriffs Erfahrung zu sein scheint. Dieser Moment ist der
Übergang vom ersten Objekt und der
Erkenntnis dieses Objekts zum anderen
Objekt. Denken Sie daran, ich sage, das erste
Objekt ist  die Darstellung des gebogenen Stocks
als befürwortet und das zweite Objekt ist
, dass dieselbe Darstellung des gebogenen
Stocks abgelehnt wird, obwohl gesagt wird, dass die
Erfahrung ist  In diesem anderen Objekt
hier ist der Übergang
so dargestellt, dass das Wissen um das
erste Objekt oder das
Bewusstseinswesen des ersten an
sich zum zweiten Objekt selbst
wird, dagegen scheint es gewöhnlich, dass wir
irgendwie ein anderes entdecken
Gegenstand ganz zufällig und nebensächlich ist
und wir darin die
Unwahrheit unseres ersten Begriffs erfahren, was
uns bei dieser gewöhnlichen Erfahrungsauffassung zufallen würde,
ist also nur die reine
Erfassung des an und für
sich Seienden vom Standpunkt der Gegenwart aus
Untersuchung zeigt sich jedoch, dass das neue Objekt
durch eine Umkehrung des Bewusstseins
selbst entstanden ist, möchte er, dass wir uns auf die
Aktivität der Entscheidung konzentrieren, die Repräsentation des gebogenen Stocks abzulehnen und die
Repräsentation des
geraden Stocks zu akzeptieren, also erkennt Hegel hier
ausdrücklich an, dass es eine
Gefahr gibt  Irreführung durch die Art und Weise, wie
er die Erfahrung des Irrtums beschreibt,
bestätigt er ausdrücklich die Lektüre, die ich
habe  en Angebot des zweiten das neue wahre
Objekt ist er sagt Zitat das Sein für
Bewusstsein des ersten an sich die
Umkehrung des Bewusstseins ist die
Statusänderung des Stockes ist gebogen
propositionaler konzeptueller Inhalt
vom Befürworten als Realität zum
Ablehnen als bloßer Schein sein
Die überraschende Behauptung ist, dass dieses Element der
Erfahrung die Entlarvung dessen ist,
was angenommen wurde, um die Realität so darzustellen, wie sie an
sich tatsächlich eine bloße Erscheinung ist, eine
Darstellung, die eine
falsche Darstellung ist
, die der zentral wichtige Aspekt der
Erfahrung ist, nicht die neue Wahrnehmung,
die einen dazu bringt, sie zu billigen  Die Behauptung, dass der
Stock gerade ist, dass das neue Objekt,
das der konzeptionelle Inhalt ist, dazu gebracht wurde, dies zu bestätigen
, führt zwar zu der Erfahrung des
Irrtums, aber wenn wir uns auf das Ereignis konzentrieren,
das den Prozess zufällig fortsetzt
, wird die Erfahrung, von der er
sagt, das Notwendige und
Wesentliche verfehlen  zu diesem Prozess, wie er möchte, dass wir
ihn verstehen, diese neue Art des
Denkens über Expe  Diese Erkenntnis, die er
empfiehlt, ist wirklich der
Hauptpunkt der gesamten Einführung.
Sie ermöglicht die Art
von Erzählung, die den Rest der Phänomenologie einnimmt und
sich auf die charakteristische Umkehrung des
Bewusstseins konzentriert, durch die das, was für das
Subjekt war, so ist, wie die Dinge an sich
sind  entlarvt als bloß, wie die Dinge
für das Bewusstsein waren, wird diese Bewegung
uns Hegels Lesern eine
phänomenologische Einsicht geben, die nicht
Teil der Irrtumserfahrung des
phänomenalen Bewusstseins ist, das wir
betrachten  Materie ist unser
Beitrag, sie existiert nicht für das
Bewusstsein,
das wir beobachten, aber so gesehen
wird
die vom Bewusstsein konstituierte Erfahrungsfolge
auf die Ebene einer wissenschaftlichen
Progression gehoben. Zitatende
dieser Perspektivenwechsel diese Art
, die Entstehung zu verstehen  des
zweiten neuen wahren Objekts ist es,
was die Wissenschaft davon ermöglicht  die Erfahrung
des Bewusstseins, die sich erinnern, war der
Arbeitstitel, mit dem Hegel das
Projekt des Schreibens begann, das zur
Phänomenologie werden sollte, die besonderen Bindungen
, deren materielle
Unvereinbarkeit einen Erfahrungsprozess einleitet,
kontingent sind,
was für diesen Prozess notwendig ist, ist das
Eingeständnis des Irrtums und  die
darauffolgende desillusionierung, dass es
zu dem nötigen führt,
ist zitat die bewegung, die erkenntnis ist die
wandlung des an sich in
das für sich
nah zitat wie hegel ganz am
ende des buches sagt an dieser stelle unserer
geschichte verstehen wir was  diese Bewegung
ist, aber wir sehen noch nicht, warum sie der Schlüssel
zur Wissenschaft der Erfahrung des
Bewusstseins ist, und das ist das Thema
des letzten Abschnitts dieses Vortrags, wie Hegel
uns sagt, dass der Schlüssel zum Verständnis
der Bedeutung des
Perspektivwechsels, der er ist  Es ist dringend geboten,
die Bedeutung
der Rolle von w für die drohende Skepsis zu durchdenken
was in der Erfahrung durch den
Begriff der bestimmten Negation deutlich gemacht wird, fährt der
vorletzte Absatz der
Einleitung fort,
tatsächlich ist der Umstand, der
diese Art der Beobachtung leitet, derselbe wie
der zuvor in Bezug auf
das Verhältnis zwischen der vorliegenden
Untersuchung besprochene  und Skepsis in jedem Fall darf sich das
Ergebnis, das aus einer
unwahren Erkenntnisweise hervorgeht, nicht
in ein leeres Nichts auflösen, sondern
muss notwendigerweise als das
Nichts dessen erfasst werden, dessen Ergebnis es ein
Ergebnis ist, das das Wahre
des Vorhergehenden enthält  Erkenntnis im
vorliegenden Kontext
manifestiert sich dieser Umstand wie folgt, wenn das,
was zuerst als Objekt erschienen war
, zum Bewusstsein der Kunst auf die Ebene des Seins sinkt
und wenn das An sich ein Wesen
für das Bewusstsein des An sich wird, dann ist
dies  das neue objekt geschlossen quad jetzt denke ich
an dieser stelle haben wir uns
in die lage gebracht zu verstehen  Und dieser letzte
Satz darüber, wie die Änderung des
normativen Status, den ein Inhaltsbeurteiler
erfährt, wenn das Subjekt eine
frühere Bestätigung zurückzieht, was er
als Bewusstseinsumkehr bezeichnet, ist
als das Auftauchen eines neuen Objekts verständlich,
aber was hat das mit
der Einstellung zu tun wir  In Richtung
Skepsis stellen sollte sich das Problem stellen, weil die
Expository-Trajektorie Aufgrund der
Expository-Trajektorie, die wir in
meinem ersten Vortrag durchlaufen haben, behaupte ich, dass wir
die Eröffnung der Einführung lesen sollten, da
Bedenken bestehen, dass erkenntnistheoretische Skepsis
uns nicht schon durch unsere Semantik aufgezwungen wird
Eine spezifischere Diagnose
lautete, dass uns Skepsis aufgezwungen wird,
wenn wir das Verhältnis zwischen
Erscheinung und Wirklichkeit als ein Verhältnis auffassen, in dem
begriffliche Inhalte für die Darstellung von x'
nicht begrifflich strukturierten
Repräsentierten gegenüberstehen, was sich dann als
Kluft der Verständlichkeit abzeichnet, behauptete ich
weiter, die von Hegel vorgeschlagen wurde  Therapie
deutete auf die Einführung hin und
entwickelte sich hinein  Die Bewusstseinskapitel sollen
konzeptuellen Inhalt mit
deterministischem Aynd der Negation identifizieren, das ist im
Prinzip, wenn das im Spiel ist,
wenn Hegel das Spinoza-Prinzip dazu liest,
bestimmen ah gee Oeste Gaudio,
seine bestimmte Negation
, die den aristotelischen Gegensätzen entspricht, nicht dem
aristotelischen Widerspruch x', was
verstanden werden würde  In Bezug auf die formale
oder abstrakte Negation ist das bestimmte
Nosov ein Gedanke oder Sachverhalt eine
Frage des modal robusten Ausschlusses
anderer Gedanken oder Sachverhalte,
die mit dieser Konzeption materiell unvereinbar sind, und
erlaubt es Hegel, eine
andere zentrale Spinosus-Doktrin zu unterstützen, in der
Spinoza sagt  Verbindung von
Dingen ist die gleiche wie die Reihenfolge in
Verbindung von Ideen und das Zitat für
diesen Begriff der Determinante dies gilt
gleichermaßen für dargestellte Dinge und Gedanken
Sand repräsentiert keine Kluft der
Verständlichkeit wird zwischen
Erscheinung und Realität ausgehoben
eine bestimmte Gedanken und bestimmende
Sachverhalte  rs sind
sowohl begrifflich inhaltsvoll als auch
prinzipiell verständlich
erkenntnistheoretische Skepsis
in diese Semantik von vornherein eingebaut, in
diesem Zusammenhang gibt es keinen Grund,
den semantischen Zusammenhang zwischen
Schein und Wirklichkeit nicht
repräsentational, sondern
begrifflich inhaltsmäßig zu verstehen  Der
Begriff der bestimmenden Negation erlaubt nicht
nur eine solche
Repräsentationskontrolle in Hegels Händen, er
ermöglicht auch eine konstruktive Analyse der
Repräsentationsdimension,
die er im Begriffsgehalt implizit vorfindet. Hegel
verbindet diesen grundlegenden Aspekt von
Spinozas Denken mit der strukturellen
Isomorphie der Ordnung in Verbindung  von
Dingen und Ideen, die in Bezug auf
Beziehungen der bestimmenden Negation zu einer
inhaltlichen Idee konstruiert werden, die Spinoza nicht hatte,
denn Spinoza hat den
besonderen normativen Charakter dessen, was
er die Ordnung in Verbindung mit Ideen nannte, nicht gewürdigt,
die sie von der
Ordnung in Verbindung mit o unterscheidet  Wenn die Hegel-
Synthese von Spinoza mit Kant darauf ankommt,
kann Semantik und Pragmatik nicht genug begründet werden
, hängt davon ab,
was man tun muss, um
Verantwortung für einen bewertbaren
Begriffsgehalt zu übernehmen. In meinem zweiten Vortrag habe
ich einstudiert, wie Hegels
Erfahrungsbericht  des Irrtums, was er aus
Kants kritischer integrativer Aufgabe macht,
eine
Konstellation von Verpflichtungen zu synthetisieren, die
die rationale Einheit besitzt, die für eine Wahrnehmung kennzeichnend ist
, die diese Geschichte unterschreibt,
ein implizites praktisches Verständnis
von Repräsentationsgehalt, das
Kant Hegels Konzept der bestimmten
Negation nachgelagert ist, dementsprechend ein
Wesen enthält  Das dynamische Element ergibt
sich aus der entscheidenden verbleibenden Asymmetrie
zwischen der Ordnung und Verbindung von
Ideen und der von Dingen. Es ist unmöglich,
dass ein Objekt gleichzeitig
materiell unvereinbare Eigenschaften
aufweist  Enten, die den Zaren repräsentieren,
artikuliert durch deontisch normative
Beziehungen, die gut vertreten sind
, werden durch Ali artikuliert. Dick modale diejenigen
, die sich mit materiell
unvereinbaren Verpflichtungen wiederfinden, verpflichten
uns, etwas zu tun, um diese Verpflichtungen zu revidieren
, um die Inkohärenz zu beseitigen,
die wir nur in Bezug auf diese Verpflichtung zur Reparatur können  zu verstehen, was es heißt
, objektive Eigenschaften
oder Sachverhalte als unvereinbar und
als einzige Sache modalen Sinns zu nehmen oder zu behandeln, um
die repräsentationale Dimension von
konzeptuellen Inhalten zu
verstehen, erfordert das Verständnis, wie die
normativ artikulierte Erfahrung von Fehlern
als Repräsentation von
objektiv dickem Modal verständlich ist  Relationen der
Inkompatibilität bestimmen Negation
materiell Inkompatibilität vermittelt das
Verhältnis zwischen Pragmatik und
Semantik sowie das Verhältnis
zwischen den expressiven und
repräsentationalen Dimensionen der
Intentionalität auf der semantischen Seite aber
die Offenbarung, die den semantischen enischen
Kern ausmacht  Erfahrung der
Erfahrungsaspekt, der für die
Repräsentationsdimension der
Intentionalität verantwortlich ist, dass der semantisch-genetische
Kern der Erfahrung die Erfahrung ist,
die Erfahrung des Irrtums, dass ihr Wesen darin
besteht, etwas zu entlarven, das nicht
real ist, sondern als bloße Erscheinung
das Gespenst noch einmal heraufzubeschwören scheint
Skepsis, wenn Irrtum die notwendige
Form von Erfahrung ist,
wenn man implizit entdeckt, dass
Erfahrung immer die Richtigkeit
und Unzulänglichkeit des eigenen Wissens oder
Verständnisses ist, warum ist Skepsis nicht
die richtige Schlussfolgerung, um zu ziehen,
warum sich Hegels eigener Begriff der
Erfahrung nicht als was gezeigt hat  er nennt
den Weg der Verzweiflung Hegel will
die Beziehung zwischen den beiden Objekten verstehen,
was er das erste an
sich nennt und was er das Sein für das
Bewusstsein des an sich nennt, als eines der
Verneinung er sagt Zitat dieses neue Objekt
enthält das Nichts des Bedürftigen
drachen des ersten es ist, welche erfahrungen daraus
gemacht werden
, zum zitat die idee ist t  Die Skepsis
besteht darin, den Sinn, in dem
das zweite Objekt die Negation des
ersten ist, für eine formale oder abstrakte Negation zu halten
und nicht für eine bestimmte Negation
, die das Ergebnis, das
aus der unwahren
Erkenntnisweise hervorgeht, in leeres
Nichts und Sagen auflösen lässt  Wie die Dinge wirklich
sind, ist
es eine Erscheinung eine falsche Darstellung
eines geraden Stocks, der die
materiell unvereinbare Verpflichtung ist, für
die die gebogene Stangendarstellung
verworfen wurde, die ihren normativen Status ändert
Das
Erscheinen einer Realität Es ist wirklich
ein Erscheinen dieser Realität Ein Weg, wie sich die
Realität dem Bewusstsein zeigt Es ist
falsch, aber es ist nicht einfach falsch Es ist ein
Weg zur Wahrheit Wenn Hegel sagt, zitieren Sie
das Ergebnis, das aus einer
unwahren Erkenntnisweise hervorgeht  begriffen als das
Nichts dessen, dessen Ergebnis in seinem
Ergebnis ein Ergebnis ist, das was enthält  das stimmt
nach vorkenntnissen ende des zitats
das ist also im doppelsinne erstens wird die
ursprüngliche auffassung der dinge nicht einfach
lückenhaft aufgehoben, wie es ein bloßer
widerspruch tun würde, sondern
durch eine gegensätzliche
materielle verbindlichkeit ersetzt  nicht
nur formal unvereinbar damit
etwas positives gelernt wurde der
stick ist gerade 2. der übergang
vom ursprünglichen objekt zum zweiten
wahren objekt ist ein
statuswechsel von einer dem subjekt detekto beschreibbaren propositionalen haltung zu einer
auch de ray we're zuschreibbaren  bevor wir und das
Subjekt sagen konnten, dass s glaubt, dass der
Stock verbogen ist
, ist nach der Erfahrung des
Irrtums und der Zurückweisung der ursprünglichen
Billigung zugunsten eines materiell
gegensätzlichen die gleiche Haltung
zuzuschreiben wie s glaubt
, dass es einem geraden Stock entspricht  ist gebogen
, das ist der strahlcharakter
, das ist der punkt der analyse des
gegenständlichen gehalts und seiner
erfahrungsaufnahme  Der Irrtum,
den ich letztes Mal besprochen habe, ist die
Statustransformation eine
Zurückweisung einer vorherigen Billigung, aber nicht nur
eine Zurückweisung in einem wichtigen Sinne,
sondern eine Bereicherung ihres Inhalts, da sie
für das Subjekt zu einer Behauptung über etwas wird, das eine
repräsentative Dimension hat
ihres konzeptionellen Gehalts
offenbar wird, wenngleich durch ihre Entlarvung
als Fehlrepräsentation, wie wir im
ersten Vortrag gesehen haben, ist
die Unverständlichkeit dieser
Repräsentationsdimension
bezeichnend für die
semantisch wurzelnde erkenntnistheoretische
Skepsis, die Hegel in den
einleitenden Absätzen der
Einleitung diagnostiziert, die nicht verwundert  Dieser Punkt, um dann zu lernen,
dass der charakteristische
Mangel des Skeptizismus ein Versäumnis ist, sich
der Rolle der bestimmten
Negation zu stellen, wenn es darum geht, Konsequenzen aus
der Erfahrung des Irrtums zu ziehen, sagt er, zitieren, dass
die Darstellung des unwahren Bewusstseins
in seiner Unwahrheit keine bloß negative
Bewegung als natürliches Bewusstsein ist.
seitlich  sie ansieht und eine
Erkenntnisweise, die diese Einseitigkeit zu
ihrem Grundprinzip macht, ist die Skepsis,
die in jedem Ergebnis nur reines
Nichts sieht und davon abstrahiert,
dass dieses Nichts bestimmt ist,
dass es das Nichts dessen ist,
woraus es tatsächlich resultiert  nur wenn das
Nichts als das Nichts dessen genommen wird
, woraus es
das wahre Ergebnis ist, denn dann ist das Nichts
selbst ein bestimmtes Nichts und
hat einen Inhalt, der Skeptizismus, der
bei der Abstraktion des Nichts
oder bei der Leere endet, kann nicht
weitergehen  sondern abwarten müssen, ob
sich ihm etwas Neues darbietet und
was dies ist, um es
in dieselbe abgrundtiefe Leere zu werfen, aber wenn
umgekehrt das Resultat so wie
es wirklich ist als bestimmte Negation begriffen wird, so
ist damit sofort eine neue Form
entstanden  dieses langen Zitats nur von dem
Standpunkt aus, den er empfiehlt, können wir
die Tatsache verstehen, dass in jeder
Erfahrung Fehler vorhanden sind
positiv gelernt ist eines der Teile
des Puzzles und eines der Teile von
Hegels Lösung, die ich
hier hinzugefügt zu haben hoffe, ist das Verständnis dafür,
wie die darstellende Dimension des
begrifflichen Inhalts nicht weniger als seine
expressive Dimension
in Begriffen des verständlich wird  Die wesentliche
konstitutive Rolle, die die bestimmende
Negation im
Erfahrungsprozess spielt, kann dennoch gefragt werden,
warum Hegels
Erfahrungsbericht nicht die Erfahrung des Irrtums
als Entlarvung dessen ist, was wir für
Realität hielten, als Erscheinung als Offenbarung dessen,
was zwei Subjekte waren  die Art und Weise, wie die
Dinge an sich sind, ihre Offenbarung als
bloß das, was sie für das
Bewusstsein sind, warum liefert das nicht
genau die Prämisse, die für eine
fallibiistische Meta-Induktion benötigt wird?
Unser Urteil hat
sich schließlich zumindest im Detail als falsch herausgestellt
und kommt zu dem Schluss, dass
z  Jeder Glaube oder jedes Urteil, das wir je haben werden oder
haben könnten, wird ebenso
schließlich als mangelhaft befunden werden, wenn wir es nur
früh in der Einleitung einer ausreichenden kritischen Prüfung unterziehen.
Hegel sagt uns, dass diese skeptische
Schlussfolgerung für diejenigen
, die die Lektionen noch nicht gelernt haben, eine natürliche ist
er lehrt uns, er sagt, das natürliche
Bewusstsein wird sich als
bloßes Konzept von Wissen oder
unwirklichem Wissen erweisen, aber da es
sich sofort als wirkliches Wissen annimmt, hat
dieser Weg eine negative
Bedeutung für es und was ist eigentlich
die Verwirklichung des Konzepts  für ihn
eher als den Verlust und die
Zerstörung seiner selbst, denn auf diesem
Weg verliert er seine Wahrheit, der Weg kann
daher als der Weg des Zweifels oder
besser als der Weg der Verzweiflung angesehen werden, dieser
Weg ist die bewusste Einsicht in die
Unwahrheit des Phänomens  wissen schließen
zitieren was man lernen muss um zu sehen
was man lernen muss um zu sehen dass
dies die falsche schlussfolgerung ist das zentrale
sema  ntische Bedeutung der
Irrtumserfahrung für die Verständlichkeit der
Repräsentationsdimension von
Begriffsinhalten,
sondern um die positive
Bedeutung der Entlarvung von
Bindungen als dezidiert irrtümlich zu verstehen,
da korrigierte Fehldarstellungen eine
inhaltlich neue Auffassung von Wahrheit
erfordern, die sich
im Körper entwickelt  der Phänomenologie und nur
angedeutet im einleitenden Material
wird es angedeutet, aber schon
im Vorwort sagt er Zitat Wahrheit beinhaltet
das Negative auch das, was man
das Falsche nennen könnte, wenn man es als
etwas ansehen könnte, von dem man
das eigentliche Muss abstrahieren könnte  Im Gegenteil,
als wesentlich nicht als etwas
Feststehendes, von der wahren Erscheinung abgeschnittenes anzusehen
ist das Entstehen und Vergehen,
das nicht selbst entsteht und vergeht,
sondern an sich ist und die Wirklichkeit
und die Bewegung des Lebens der Wahrheit
und des Zitats ausmacht
Wahrheit als einen erreichbaren Zustand oder Prozess zu denken
Gel möchte, dass wir denken, dass „Entschuldigung“ ein
erreichbarer Zustand oder Status ist. Hegel möchte, dass
wir es als ein Merkmal
eines Prozesses betrachten
bestätigt, wie
sie in sich selbst sind, wenn
sie als materiell unvereinbar mit
anderen Verpflichtungen in der Erfahrung des
Irrtums befunden werden, einige werden abgelehnt, eine
Statustransformation, die das Entstehen des
zweiten wahren Objekts ist, die Erscheinung als eine
falsche Darstellung, die es nur zum
Bewusstsein wird  Wie die Dinge sind oder
waren für das Bewusstsein Dieser Prozess des
Abwägens der Referenzen konkurrierender
Verpflichtungen, um zu bestimmen, welche
beibehalten werden sollten, in welchen Änderungen angenommen wird,
um lokale materielle Inkompatibilitäten zu beseitigen,
ist der Prozess, durch den wir mehr darüber herausfinden,
wie die Dinge wirklich sind
diese Passage aus dem Vorwort  fährt
mit einem berühmten Bild fort, das er sagt, das
Wahre ist also ein Rücken eines Aliens  el mit
noch keinem nüchternen Mitglied, weil jedes
Mitglied zusammenbricht, sobald er aussteigt,
das Schwelgen ist genauso viel Transport
und einfache Repos. Ende des Zitats, die Wahrheit
ist ein riesiger Rücken, ein Alien, ein Fest
Als
unvereinbar werden diejenigen, die aussteigen,
diejenigen entdeckt, die eine Transformation der
Erfahrung durchlaufen und abgelehnt werden,
um die rationale Homöostase aufrechtzuerhalten, die
Hegel als einen Zustand der einfachen Ruhe identifiziert,
die die Partei in ihrer
Bewegung und Entwicklung fortsetzt, weil der
Platz derer, die ausfallen  weggenommen wird
sofort von anderen Verpflichtungen
dieser axiale Abschnitt aus dem Vorwort
wird in einer Weise fortgesetzt, die drei Themen einleitet,
mit denen ich durch
Diskussionszitate
enden möchte  - aber sie sind
ebenso positive und notwendige wie
negative und sogar wesentliche
Momente dieser Bewegung  Nicht als
Ruhezustand gesehen, was sich
darin auszeichnet und sich eine besondere
Existenz gibt, wird als etwas bewahrt, das
sich selbst erinnert, dessen Existenz
Selbsterkenntnis ist und dessen
Selbsterkenntnis ebenso unmittelbar Existenz
Ende des Zitats zuerst der Wahrheitsprozess
dessen ist  Struktur ist die
Erfahrung des Irrtums ist der Prozess, durch
den begriffliche Inhalte entstehen
und bestimmt werden nicht nur der Prozess,
durch den Urteile ausgewählt werden, sondern auch
der Prozess, durch den Konzepte entstehen,
es ist der Prozess, in und durch den
immer mehr wie die  Welt ist wirklich
das, was eigentlich
materiell unvereinbar ist mit dem, was im
objektiven olitischen Sinn
in materielle
Unvereinbarkeiten eingegliedert wird Dejantisch
anerkannt von Subjekten für die eigene
Reaktion auf die anerkannte
Unvereinbarkeit zweier Verpflichtungen, mit denen man
sich konfrontiert sieht, besteht oft darin,
seine Verpflichtungen in Bezug auf das, was
unvereinbar ist, anzupassen  mit was und so was
folgt  Was wäre, wenn mein anfängliches
Konzept eines Vermögenswerts mich dazu zwingt, es auf
jede Flüssigkeit anzuwenden, die sauer schmeckt, und die Anwendung
mich dazu verpflichtet, dass
sich Lackmuspapier rot färbt? Ich könnte
auf eine saure Flüssigkeit reagieren, die
Lackmuspapier blau färbt, und auf die
Unverträglichkeit dieser  Zwei-Farben-
Verpflichtungen, nicht indem wir entweder das
Wahrnehmungsurteil von Sauer oder das
Wahrnehmungsurteil von Blau ablehnen, sondern indem
wir die Normen revidieren, die das Konzept artikulieren.
Ich könnte zum Beispiel annehmen,
dass nur klare Flüssigkeiten, die sauer schmecken,
oder Säuren oder die trüben Säuren sich nicht verfärben
Lackmuspapierrot,
weil die
normativ artikulierten Begriffsinhalte
, die die Subjekte anerkennen und
anwenden, die objektive modale
Begriffsartikulation der Welt so
gut behandeln, wie sie es tun, und insofern sie das Ergebnis vieler solcher Fehlererfahrungen erben, ist dies der Grund, warum die
Fehlererfahrung ist  ein wahrheitsprozess
der zweite punkt ist, dass
hegels beschwörung des erinnerungsgeschehens allein,
auf das er erst ganz zurückkommt  Das Ende
der Phänomenologie ist eine Geste in der
dritten Phase der Erfahrung des Irrtums,
wir haben bereits die ersten beiden betrachtet, die
Anerkennung der materiellen
Unvereinbarkeit der eigenen Verpflichtungen und die
Revision der eigenen Verpflichtungen, einschließlich
derer, was mit was unvereinbar ist
, um die
Diskrepanz mit Hegel zu beheben  Calls
Recollection ist eine nachfolgende
retrospektive rationale Rekonstruktion
des erweiterten Erfahrungsprozesses
, der zu der aktuellen Konstellation von
Verpflichtungen geführt hat. Was rekonstruiert wird, ist eine
Folge von Episoden, von denen jede
die dreiphasige Struktur der
Reparatur der Anerkennung und der Erinnerung
an materiell unvereinbare Verpflichtungen aufweist, von denen
man gebilligt wird  Der eigentliche
Prozess vergangener Erfahrungen
wählt der Erinnerer eine Bahn, die sich als
ausdrucksvoll progressiv herausstellt, das heißt, als hätte
er die Form einer allmählichen kumulativen
Offenbarung dessen, wie die Dinge wirklich sind,
so der Erinnerer, es ist eine
Whiggish-Geschichte, die für die alte Mode charakteristisch ist
d Wissenschaftsgeschichten eine Geschichte
von der Art und Weise,
wie die Dinge an sich sind, wie die Art und Weise, wie die Dinge an sich sind
, zu der Art und Weise wurden, wie sie unregelmäßig
für das Bewusstsein erschienen, dass auf diese
Weise die Vergangenheit ständig zu einem
sein
DeRay wird, bei jeder Dreiteilung anders
Episode der Erfahrung ist, wie Hegel
Vernunft so retrospektiv versteht, wie
er sagt, Kontingenz die Form der
Notwendigkeit geben Der dritte Punkt ist, dass die
Erinnerungsphase der Erfahrung ein
entscheidendes Element in dem ist, was Hegel die
Wissenschaft der Erfahrung des
Bewusstseins nennt, so weit in diesen Vorträgen
I  Ich habe viel über die Erfahrung
des Bewusstseins gesprochen, aber nicht offiziell
über die Wissenschaft der Erfahrung des
Bewusstseins, und dies hat möglicherweise
zu einiger Verwirrung geführt, warum ich wann
über die Rolle und Erfahrung weltlicher
Konzepte wie gebogener Stock und gerader
Stock spreche  Das Buch, das Hegel
uns vorstellt, konzentriert sich ausschließlich auf Konzepte
wie Bewusstsein, Selbstbewusstsein
und Handlungsfähigkeit  Was ich zum
Begriff der kognitiven Autorität sagen würde, ist die
gesellschaftliche Autoritätsinstitution und
praktische Autorität, warum habe ich
die Entwicklung
von Urteils- und Begriffskonstellationen diskutiert,
wenn es Hegel zumindest in der
zweiten Hälfte der Einleitung um die
Entwicklung dessen geht  er nennt
solche Fragen Formen des Bewusstseins
gut verständlich oder ich denke fehl am Platz,
obwohl ich nicht ausdrücklich darüber
gesprochen habe, was ich getan habe, ist eine
Übung der Wissenschaft der
Erfahrung des Bewusstseins, denn diese
Wissenschaft ist das explizite systematische
selbstbewusste Verstehen  Was die
Erfahrung des Bewusstseins betrifft, nehme ich an,
dass jedes Verständnis von Hegel oder
Conte mit dem beginnen sollte, was
er uns über gewöhnliche
empirische und praktische
Erfahrung auf grundlegender Ebene zu lehren hat, denn für Hegel wie für Kant geht es
darum, das anzuwenden, was Hegel
Determiniertheit nennt  Konzepte das sind Konzepte
wie Stick und Straight und Blue und
Sauer, was Hagel s nannte  Spekulative oder
logische Konzepte sind theoretische
philosophische Metakonzepte, deren
unverwechselbare Ausdrucksfunktion es ist
, Merkmale der konzeptuellen Inhalte explizit zu machen
und die Semantik und
Pragmatik dieser sehr grundlegenden
Konzepte zu verwenden. Die Phänomenologie ist eine Geschichte, eine
erinnerte Geschichte über die
Entwicklung dieser höheren  -Ebene Konzepte,
mit denen seine Leser das
phänomenologische Bewusstsein dazu bringen können,
diskursive
Aktivitäten im allgemeinen phänomenalen
Bewusstsein zu verstehen, liegt das Maß unseres
Verständnisses dessen, was er zu diesem Thema zu sagen hat,
hauptsächlich in dem Sinn, den
wir mit diesen Metakonzepten machen können
der ganzen Konstellation
konzeptionell artikulierter normativer
Praktiken und Institutionen, die Hegel
Geist nennt
, deshalb habe ich meine Geschichte mit dem begonnen,
was er meiner Meinung nach uns altum Utley
über die damalige Erfahrung des Bewusstseins verstehen lassen will,
und ich denke nur dann
und auf dieser Grundlage  Wir können uns überlegen, was
es heißt, das de zu rendern  Entwicklung
beider Arten von Konzepten in wissenschaftlichen
Begriffen im Hegel-Sinn bedeutet
, eine bestimmte Art von
retrospektiver, rational rekonstruktiver
Geschichte über ihre Entwicklung zu erzählen,
die eine ausdrücklich progressive
Geschichte aus der Vergangenheit zeigt, von der dies die
dritte Phase ist  der Prozess der Erfahrung,
der durch die
Anerkennung der materiellen Unvereinbarkeit einiger
Verpflichtungen eingeleitet wird, der durch die
lokale und vorübergehende Auflösung dieser
Inkohärenz fortgeführt wird, indem
einige Verpflichtungen aufgegeben oder geändert werden, einschließlich
derjenigen, die betreffen, was materiell
unvereinbar ist mit oder eine Folge davon,
während andere beibehalten werden und
kulminiert im Begreifen der
Erfahrung, indem sie sie als
aktuelles Ergebnis eines Prozesses verortet, in dem
frühere Verpflichtungen sich als
immer aufschlussreichere, aber letztlich immer noch
unzureichende Erscheinungen für das
Bewusstsein dessen erweisen, was man jetzt davon hält, dass die Dinge an
sich der Schlussstein von Hegels
Darstellung sind  das Ende von  Das Vernunftkapitel
und weiter am Ende des
Geistkapitels wird es sein, uns zu zeigen, wie diese
retrospektiv rational rekonstruierende
genealogische Phase des
Erfahrungsprozesses bedeutet, dass solche
Erfahrung zugleich die weitere
Bestimmung des Inhalts von Begriffen ist,
ob sie wie Säure bestimmt sind  oder
philosophisch
wie Selbstbewusstsein im Sinne
der expressiven Dimension des
Begriffsinhalts jener Intentionalität, die sich
durch Determinantenbeziehungen der
Negation artikuliert und zugleich das
Erkennen der Referenz aber Deutschzwiebel dessen ist,
was die Dinge an sich
sind, die durch solche Sinne repräsentiert werden Zinna
Was die Dinge für das Bewusstsein entlang
der Repräsentationsdimension des
konzeptuellen Inhalts der Intentionalität sind, wie
sie durch den Prozess artikuliert wird, der die
Erfahrung des Fehlers ist, der normativ
von Beziehungen der bestimmenden Negation bestimmt wird, aber
das ist eine Geschichte für eine andere Gelegenheit, die
Hegel für die einzige Form des
theoretischen Verständnisses hält
C  Begriffs- und Repräsentationsgehalt
eines Konzepts annehmen kann, ist eine solche
Genealogie eines Erfahrungsprozesses, durch
die bestimmt wird,
ob es sich um eine
Konstellation von Konzepten und
Verpflichtungen auf der Metallebene des
wissenschaftlichen Selbstbewusstseins oder auf der
Grundebene handelt  des empirischen phänomenalen
Bewusstseins, deshalb assimiliert er
sie in der Vorrede, die ich
gerade betrachtet habe, er sagt Zitat:
Vor dem Gericht dieser Erfahrungsbewegung beurteilt, bestehen
die einzelnen Geistesformen
auf der Metaebene
nicht mehr als bestimmte Gedanken  auf der
bodenebene, aber sie sind ebenso
positive und notwendige momente wie
sie negativ und sogar essentiell sind
Erfahrung der Wissenschaft der
Erfahrung des Bewusstseins der Prozess,
durch den Metakonzepte er  für
ausreichend hält, um den Prozess der Erfahrung explizit zu verstehen,
selbst
entwickelt und bestimmt sind, sehen wir, wie Hegel
behauptet, dass die Formen des Irrtums und es
tut uns leid, dass die Erfahrung des Irrtums
hier beschrieben wird, auch der Mechanismus ist,
durch den neue Formen des Bewusstseins
in einer Passage entstehen, die wir  re jetzt in der
lage zu lesen
und zu verstehen, sagt er, wenn das,
was zuerst als das objekt erscheint,
auf die ebene des seins zum bewusstsein sinkt,
ein wissen des objekts,
und wenn das an sich ein seiendes
für das bewusstsein des an sich wird, dann
dies  das neue Objekt ist und mit diesem neuen
Objekt auch eine neue Bewußtseinsform in
Erscheinung tritt, eine Form,
deren Wesen etwas anderes ist als das,
was der vorangegangenen Wesensform war,
dieser Umstand
leitet die ganze Abfolge
der Bewußtseinsformen  in seiner Notwendigkeit,
aber es ist diese Notwendigkeit allein oder das
Auftauchen des neuen Objekts, das
sich dem Bewußtsein ohne th darstellt
Das Wissen des letzteren, wie ihm dies geschieht,
das sich gleichsam hinter
seinem Rücken für uns ereignet, ein Moment, das sowohl an
sich als auch für uns ist, wird dadurch
in die Bewegung des Bewusstseins eingeführt, ein
Moment, das sich für
das mit der Erfahrung beschäftigte Bewusstsein nicht darstellt
selbst, aber der Inhalt dessen,
was wir auftauchen sehen, existiert für ihn und
wir begreifen nur den formalen Aspekt des
Auftauchens oder reines Auftauchen für das
Bewusstsein, was auftaucht, existiert
nur als Objekt, für uns existiert es
zugleich als Bewegung und ein Werden, dies ist es
dann  die Notwendigkeit, kraft derer
der jetzige Weg zur Wissenschaft
selbst schon eine Wissenschaft ist und
seinem Inhalt
nach die Wissenschaft der Bewußtseinserfahrung genannt werden darf
Ende des Zitats
Ich habe mich in diesen Vorträgen auf das konzentriert, worüber
Hegel zu sagen haben wird  die Semantik und
Pragmatik der Konzepte, die
zur Vorbereitung auf das Verständnis
des Verlaufs der Erfahrung eingesetzt und durch Basiserfahrung bestimmt werden  riez des Selbstbewusstseins auf der
Metaebene, das er
für uns im Körper der
Phänomenologie zusammenfasst, dafür ist dies eine
Einführung, um Ihnen zu danken